boy out of all the conditions that a
person can experience shingles is right
up there as far as how it can impact
someone's life almost with some people
to the point of suicide shingles comes
from this virus called the varicella
disaster and it's a virus that is latent
or dormant in your body so some people
can experience this virus coming out of
remission and creating this severely
painful rash so I'm going to talk about
that as well as what you can do to get
some relief right now as well as well
more importantly to keep this virus in
remission but to do that you have to
understand a little bit about the nature
of this virus so I first want to just
share some data that really aligns with
what we're going to use as a treatment
the first thing to know is that it's a
weakness within your own immune system
which is kind of good news because it
puts you in the driver's seat you can
control this virus if you understand a
little bit about the immune system but
the first thing you need to know is that
certain things will trigger this virus
coming out of remission certain drugs
will do it being on Prednisone will do
it even though that sometimes is part of
the treatment but if you use this
treatment too long it creates a weakness
and then that virus starts coming out
prednisone is a kind of the medication
version of cortisol which is a hormone
activated by stress and so stress
because it can paralyze your immune
system or lower your defenses lower your
white blood cells can make you very
susceptible to having this virus come
out of remission so anything that
dampens the immune system or suppresses
the immune system will cause this
reactivation of the virus this is why
radiation is also a trigger of
reactivation now let's just think about
radiation I'm not just talking about
being in front of an x-ray but that
could do it but I'm also talking about
the Sun not regular sun exposure but if
if you burn yourself or you get too much
sun so a sunburn can be a reactivation
because that's too much UV but the
Melatonin from the Sun can also be very
beneficial and pesticides in your food
supply and your environment can also be
a trigger but there's something else
that's much much bigger as far as an a
triggering for this virus and that is
are you ready for this are you sitting
down it's a low vitamin D state or a
condition makes you very very
susceptible to having this virus come
out of remission let's take a little bit
of a deep dive into the relationship of
vitamin D and this virus all right the
first piece of data is that shingles is
worsened with a low vitamin D situation
people that live further from the
equator are up more at risk for getting
shingles and that also correlates with
vitamin D as well people that are
treated with vitamin D have a much less
risk of getting a reoccurrence from
shingles people that are on dialysis
have a 16 times less chance of getting
an outbreak of shingles if they take
vitamin D another huge risk factor for
getting shingles is people with high
blood pressure and it just so happens
that 90 of high blood pressure is
essential which means it's an unknown
cause there's also a high correlation
with people with Ms that have outbreaks
with shingles and probably the one of
the best treatments that Ms responds to
is high doses of Vitamin D there are
definitely hundreds of different ways
that vitamin D helps or even controls or
modulates your immune system vitamin D
increases all sorts of different
chemicals or weapons that your immune
system uses to kill viruses vitamin D
directly keeps viruses suppressed not
just this virus that's involved in
shingles but many different viruses
including Epstein-Barr virus and TB in
respiratory viruses and your white blood
cells even have the ability to make
vitamin D now you're probably going to
hear a lot more about this next thing
I'm going to talk about but the term is
polymorphism now what is that that is an
alteration in certain genes that can
affect various things in your body and
more and more people are getting
genetically tested and to find out where
they might have weaknesses within their
genetics and one very common genetic
weakness is within the vitamin D
receptor and its ability to absorb
vitamin D if you have a vitamin D
receptor polymorphism then the regular
doses of Vitamin D are just not going to
do much you're not only probably going
to be deficient vitamin D but the normal
amounts that an average person would
take don't really work on you and having
this problem also puts you at risk for
getting shingles so another thing that's
interesting about vitamin D is it's not
really a vitamin it really is a hormone
okay and it's very similar to cortisol
in what it can do as an
anti-inflammatory and also what it can
do for your immune system but without
suppressing the immune system cortisol
suppresses the immune system vitamin D
will dampen the immune system but only
if it's overreacting vitamin D will take
someone with a lowered immune system and
raise it or with too much immune system
and bring it down to where it should be
so any treatment that you would apply
cortisol or prednisone would benefit
from vitamin D and people who have
shingles are three times more likely to
have low vitamin D in their blood than
people who have never experienced this
virus but again if you have a genetic
weakness within that receptor that could
be the reason why you have an outbreak
so all this is very interesting but now
what are you going to do about it
there's three things I'm going to
recommend number one go out and get a
vitamin D cream a topical cream you can
put directly on the shingles rash okay
and you rub it in and you put this
vitamin D into the lesion at least three
times a day the next thing you want to
do is start taking vitamin D I would
also make sure your vitamin D also has
magnesium and maybe some other factors
to make it work a little bit better but
you want to take no less than 40 000 IUS
of vitamin D every single day to beef up
your levels and put this virus back into
remission and the third thing I'm going
to recommend just to really enhance this
vitamin D is to go out and get some
geranium oil it's an essential oil and
also put that topically on the lesion
wherever it is because not only is this
oil antiviral but it is also great for
pain and you're going to notice within
Prime minutes the pain is going to come
way way down and so both attacking this
from the outside in and then from the
inside out is going to be the best
strategy and so the whole goal is to
keep your resistance okay very very high
and the most powerful way to do that is
to keep your vitamin D levels where they
need to be now there's many other things
you can do but vitamin D is going to be
your best bet right now especially if
you have an acute problem now the fact
that you have shingles tells me that
your immune system probably needs more
support
so for that information I put this video
up right here check it out